sono tutti ragazzi e pervenute questo
video sono bravi j
ed oggi siamo sotto choc il gioco
sarebbe il gioco sociale convulsioni zio
devi stare calmo doveva introdurre il
gioco sarebbe il gioco di file net frank
e non gioco proprio sconosciuto d'addio
ormai sentito si chiama fi knight frank
thies chissà che gioco strano solo
ragazzi stavolta in 3d ma serio in
trance nel senso è fatto poco bene
e la cosa è strana con i ragazzi la
grafica è devastante non avete idea ma
veramente non aveva iniziato prima che
posso iniziare ti incazzi se inizio si
incazza se inizio vabbè io so se sarà
allora che se ancora non ho visto niente
ma da un paio di screenshot
ecco infatti che chi che grafica e cioè
per un [ __ ] videogame horror questa è
una delle grafiche più belle ma neanche
in out l'ass
c'è veramente una roba fantastica tra
troppo sempre
ai skrillex come in ogni gioco horror
che si rispetti cercando ma la porta è
aperta
ma sì scema ma che cazzo stai dentro
stava portare a ripensandoci non è così
male quale si sta belle asciutti ai
ragazzi sta piovendo fuori non vogliamo
far bagnare questo bel fanciullo grazie
è un giorno egli mi aprono anche le
porte degli studi ospitali qua grazie
mille ragazzi
brooke no e non hanno però aspetta c'è
un limite alla si chiude la gente dentro
le carni brutto aprite aprite vide
nunzio chi è che mi ha chiuso la porta
se erano fuori come hanno fatto a
chiudere la porta ragazzi il gioco è
bello quando dura stronzo non seriamente
legato e siamo se starò a giorno faccio
una sedia e la sedia più brutta tra
l'altro che abbia mai visto
non c entrano neanche gli obesi cockoo
le norme sono state delle no è troppo
grosso
ok c'è qualcosa di strano c'è qualcosa
di qua dei quando non c entri nella
sedia nemmeno se lo vuoi ma c'è qualcuno
in si corridoi seriamente sentito dei
passi ho visto una luce ragazzi potrebbe
essere un problema
rega
ok ma non ho fatto ma anche in tema fan
passo mi è saltato in bocca ho perso
sono bravo a questi giochi io sono un
proprio bravo me la cavo mi fate da
cortigiani siete fuori che non esco per
grazia di dio vi fate la cortesia di
rimanerci fuori almeno quello facciamo
così e non mi chiudere però la porta
lasciata aperta che segue aperta è stato
vi vedo solo chiedete siete qua va beh
mi chiudono le porte nellina neanche a
provare a uscire
devo stare qua dentro il tizio permesso
c'è un calorifero qui vuoi un calorifero
sulla faccia ti interessa te lo posso
regalare il capello addio hai perso
pacchetto questo è il cappello di
hashish che c'è un bel po che acchiappa
lì tutti gli infarti ma che c'è una
macchina vi giuro che ho sentito che
accendeva al motore di una macchina che
siamo in casa com'è possibile che la
piantina e tu hai per caso la piantina
poiché il cazzo è via via via via veloce
relazione ma cos'è famiglia ma corre
come un fulmine socom anche un
proiettile mano ma se io ho seminato
potrebbe andar peggio potrebbe piovere
ea farti scalfisce che cos'era
no no no zio no zio lo zio lo zio non è
affatto vedermi stato fatto così a
madonna che già i dodici decimi di vista
e che cazzo cazzo fai tratte posso farti
una domanda che sta facendo
di quella [ __ ] la trama stanno
scherzando ma cos'è sto schifo ed è
anche un alfa sto gioco pensate con la
sharan sono ufficiale cos'è sta roba
io non ho mai giocato ma neanche
svendermi metterà tutta stanza quando
corre e inarrestabile sto tizio lo
vedete che lì in mezzo perché sta lì
dentro sé e l'immenso e per questo li mi
fate capire come si spera in sostanza
dello schifo la metà video ancora non
capito come si esce una sostanza io come
si esce fatto inutile parlare perchè
essere così sto già ma cosa c è di
difficile ma che cazzo viene messo nel
deretano che corri così fa mica pirlone
possibile non ti puoi salvare mai se ti
vede eccetera e cioè nel deretano a
prescinder benvenuto signor [ __ ]
ci mancava solo lei non gli spaventi non
facevano passare il sindaco poiché
benvenuto praga e non se n'è mai a parte
gli scherzi vaso aiutami tu ti prego
aiuto aiuto mi fermano per malo vaso
fermalo il vaso del potere
l'affermato davvero ascoltatrici hai dei
problemi fatelo dire che non ti ferma
nessuno quando corri pro un vaso si
potere ai vasi ragazzi ne è andato non è
lì che accende la macchina non è la
macchina e si accende lui da solo di
atac e luis al motore o che vale quindi
hai spento il motore bravo vaso ragazzi
siccome non riesco a trovare una
benedetta porta per andare avanti non è
che devo fare qualcosa con lui non è che
devo disattivarlo e non lo so non piano
piano ragazzi non lo fosse vero però
devi stare fermo io mi sto pagando già
in mano abbastanza per cortesia
piuttosto che andare lì dentro che non
serva una bega per l'amor di dio non
puoi andare fuori dalla sede calling the
alla lo vedi cespuglio corri corri di
raggiungono pazienza almeno sei provato
però con restati nessuno ma è un
attestato questo io mio conte sfocando
sito io9 lui vede benissimo fra chi mi
vede da da un chilometro io non vedo un
cazzo ma cosa devo fare non è possibile
che non devo far niente rilancio una
sedia prodotto deficiente maniaco ciao
stefano ti lancio niente piansi siediti
pure tranquillo fai quello che vuoi non
mi rompere le palle buttate giorni
oddio quanto corre e basta
vade retro corso del mio pene non ho la
bei ragazzi ma è assurdo
dio si è formato non si è fermato un
cazzo
bene proprio ma niente s'è fermato non
ho capito cosa si deve fare non lo
voglio sapere
ultimo tentativo basta poi veramente
niente non ne posso veramente piuttosto
deficiente da qualche parte anche se non
so dove non c'è più è sparito
prima c'era ma non c'è più
bye bye bye bye bye buttati giù buttati
basta basta basta basta calcato le palle
mi sono attaccato le palle è veramente
adesso me lo cerco perché non è
possibile
following the following saprei alfa win
object if you just need to get schermi